-Welcome back.
I'm so excited
because this weekend is
the Final Four.
It is happening down in Houston.
You have Florida Atlantic
taking on San Diego State
and UConn facing off
against Miami, yeah.
[ Cheering ]
It is impossible to predict
who's going to go all the way,
but you're in luck
because, when it comes
to predicting things,
we have a secret weapon
-[ Squeaking ]
-and it's puppies.
[ Cheering and applause ]
It's time for
the Puppy Predictors 2023
Final Four Edition.
-♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
♪ Puppy Predictors ♪
-Welcome to the Puppy Predictors
2023 Final Four Edition.
Here's how it works --
we have four puppies,
one for each team,
and one bowl of kibble.
Whichever team's puppy gets
to the bowl first
will determine who will be
crowned the national champs.
Now, let's meet the puppies.
-[ Squeaking ]
-For Florida Atlantic, we have
Donna Braylon.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Drumroll ]
For San Diego State, we have
Kyle McAdams.
[ Cheering and applause ]
For UConn, we have
Ted Mooney.
[ Cheering and applause ]
[ Laughs ]
The square's not tall enough
for the puppies?
[ Laughter ]
And for Miami, we have
Gary Frick Jr. right there,
everybody.
[ Laughs ]
[ Rimshot ]
My God.
But first --
But first, Gary.
Alright, now, look,
before I release you guys,
I need you to listen up, okay?
-[ Squeaking ]
-Pay attention. Thank you.
Not yet.
Gary,
I want to see
a clean race, okay?
[ Laughter ]
I don't want to see
any wandering.
No, peeing,
no butt sniffing, okay?
You ready for this?
You ready, bud?
Ooh, I have a feeling.
Oh, I have a feeling.
Hi, bud.
[ Awws ]
Alright. I have a feeling.
Alright, let's do it.
Release the puppies!
[ Lullaby plays ]
Oh, here they go.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Oh, could be it.
Ooh, Miami's got a lead.
No, San Diego State.
[ Cheering and applause ]
That is -- No.
Yes! The winner!
[ Bell dinging ]
San Diego State!
[ Rimshot ]
We have a winner.
Wow. This is a nice puppy
right here.
San Diego State
is the winner right there.
Congratulations.
You will be crowned
the 2023 national champions
right there.
Guys, you heard it here first.
Enjoy the Final Four.
We'll be right back
with Edward Norton, everyone.
[ Cheering and applause ]
Hey, bud.